بعد قرابه سته اشهر من الزلزال الذي ضرب
اقليه مايقوص وتكتيكا ولقي الاف الاشخاص
فيه مسرعهم ودمرت حوالي ثلاثه الاف منزل
تسلم الامم المتحده الف منزل مشيد
للمتضررين في منطقه برمل النائيه
كما خططنا لانشاء مدرستين لدى اطلاله فصل
الربيع في هذه القريه
الساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين
تقول ان المنازل الجديده مقاومه للزلزال
وبها مدافئ ومواقد كبيره وبوابات وانواع
شمسيه تستوعب ثمانيه الاف شخص للعيش فيها
زمونك القراءه
الى قلوب المواطنين
نحن اليوم نشارك معهم فرحتهم التي لا توصف
ورغم تعهداتي منظمات الاغاثه يزعم بعض
سكان المناطق المتضرره من الزلزال انهم
يعيشون في خيام وحفر رطبه حفروها لانفسهم
ولم يتم تقديم الدعم الاوائي والغذائي
الكافي لهم
كما لم نتخذ اي اجراءات وليس لدينا معدات
للتدفئه نطالب جهات المعنيه بدعمنا ووعدت
مفوضيه الامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين
ببناء المزيد من المنازلي العام المقبل
الذي يفصلنا عنه اسبوعان فقط وسيتم
توزيعها على ضحايا الزلزال في كل من منطقه
سبيره في خوست وديان في بكتيريكا شرقي
افغانستان
يواجهه اهالي المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال
الكثير من المشاكل فالمناطق جبليه والطقس
شديد البروده يضيف معظمهم ان الطقس
البارده قد يت وفي اضرار اكثر من الزلزال
في وقت قد تتفشى بينهم الامراض الموسميه
وخاصه لدى النساء والاطفال عبد الله نادر
العربيه كابول